[موسيقى]
موجز الاخبار من الجزيره السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله نقلت صحيفه جورنال عن مسؤولين
امريكيين عن اسرائيل هي من نفذت الهجوم
على منشاه عسكريه في اصفهان وسط طيران كما
نقلت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه عن مصادر ان
الهجوم حقق اهدافه باستهدافه 4 مواقع
وكانت وزراه الدفاع الايرانيه قد اعلنت
احباطها هجوم غامض استهدف مصنعا عسكريا
بمحافظه اصفهان تبين لاحقا انه نفذ بثلاث
طائرات مسيره صغيره
قالت مصادر امنيه عراقيه ان اربعه شاحنات
استهدفت بصواريخها اطلقتها طائرات مسيره
في قريه يلهري قرب مدينه البوكمال داخل
الاراضي السوريه من جريبها قالت القناه
الثانيه عشره الاسرائيليه ان القصف استهدف
قافله تابعه لمليشيات ايرانيه كانت في
طريقها الى سوريا
على وزير الخارجيه الايراني
عبر قطر واشراف مؤتمر صحفي مع نائب رئيس
مجلس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه هي القطريه
الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن ال ثاني الى ان
قطر تحاول اعاده جميع الاطراف في الاتفاق
النووي الى التزاماتها من جانبه قال وزير
الخارجيه القطريه الشيخ محمد بن عبد
الرحمن ال ثاني خلال لقائه مع نظيره
الايرانيين الدوحه تسعى لتوفير بيئه
مولائمه لعقد جوالات تفاوض اضافيه بشان
الاتفاق
قرر رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي تعزيز الشرطه
الاسرائيليه بسرايا من الجيش لمساعدتها في
القدس والمناطق القريبه من خط التماس جاء
ذلك خلال اجتماع للحكومه بعد ساعات من
اتخاذ الطاقه من الوزاريه الاسرائيليه
المصغر سلسله قرارات انتقاميه ضد
الفلسطينيين من بينها مصادرات الحق في
السكن لاسر منفذيه العمليات وتوسيعه
والتصريح المستوطنين
هذا واغلقت قوه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي منزل
الشهيد خيري على القمه نفذ عمليه القدس
التي يتفلت عن مقتل سبعه مستوطنين واصابه
اخرين تمهيدا لهما
وصل وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه الى القاهره
في جوله تشمل الاراضي الفلسطينيه واسرائيل
بهدف مناقشه الصعيدي في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه والتخفيف من حده التوترات
وكذلك لبحث الحفاظ على الوضع التاريخي في
القدس وملف في حل الدولتين وملفات الاخرى
قالت الهيئه العليا المستقله للانتخابات
في تونس سن النسبه العامه الاوليه
للمشاركه في الدور الثاني للانتخابات
البرلمانيه تجاوزت 11 في المئه في انتظار
اعلان النتائج النهائيه ورفضت الهيئه
التهامات التزوير الداعيه للنقاش موضوعيا
بشان بسبب المشاركه
وقال احمد نجيب الشاذلي رئيس جبهه الخلاصه
الوطنيه التونسيه ان نتائج الانتخابات
اظهرتنا في المئه من الشعب التونسي سحبت
الثقه واداره ظهورهم للعمليه الانتخابيه
انت هذا الموجز السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[موسيقى]